Hey what's up guys, I'm Tony Gonzalez, I'm here with Bleacher Report,
and this is: Build Your Squad.
All right, I'm gonna pick my all-time NFL squad.
Well, you always gotta start with a quarterback, so I'm going to start with...
Joe Montana.
My guy. I grew up in L.A. watching all those great 49er teams back in the '80s.
And then playing for the Kansas City Chiefs
where he played for the last couple years of his career,
I loved him.
Threw a perfect ball, nice little spiral, looked very catchable.
And you want that as a guy who catches the ball, so I gotta go with him.
Then from there we'll go with...
the running backs.
I'm gonna take Barry Sanders.
Loved watching him. I was a Tecmo Bowl guy too,
and when you had Barry Sanders playing Tecmo Bowl,
you couldn't be tackled. He was the guy.
Just couldn't tackle him.
And he's, he's so little, he's a little guy, and they couldn't get a hold of him,
so I loved watching him play.
Uhh...
wide...
oh I'mma,
I'mma,
I'mma go with him.
I'mma go with Tony Gonzalez
because I think it would be silly not to pick myself.
And I owe it to myself, ya know?
And I'm proud of myself,
I'm not gonna lie.
And, uh, I was pretty good for a while.
I'm gonna go Lawrence Taylor, come on.
Lawrence Taylor,
"Let's go out there like a bunch of crazed dogs and have some fun!"
I don't know if you remember him saying that, but
Lawrence Taylor said it. I didn't say that.
That guy was the man.
Sacks, against the run, everything else, and then...
after that...
I'm taking...
Reggie White.
The most dominant defensive player
I've ever seen. I had a chance to actually play against him towards the end of his career.
But just a guy—in the locker room too, you need somebody in the locker room
to get everybody's spirit right before the game,
but then go out there like a madman and terrorize opponents.
So that's a good squad right there.
I think we can beat anybody. I'd love to see everybody else's squad,
cuz I think that beats everybody.
What's missing from this team is,
well, you need a wide receiver.
Cuz I don't wanna be just the main guy and—
I'm fast but I'm not that fast. I need somebody to get over the top...
so if I'm adding a guy, it's gonna be um...
I'll probably, I'mma go with Randy.
Randy Moss, the one-handed catches, the freak speed,
just a 4.2 guy—I don't know how fast he was but—
jumping up over everybody with this guy throwing the ball, Joe Montana,
to Randy Moss, it can't be beat.
If you got him going over the top, me working the middle
and Barry Sanders out of the backfield, you can't stop that.
These two, I don't care who you are, you're not blocking these two guys, so,
lock picks.
Lock 'em in.
So this is my squad. Obviously Joe Montana, to me, the greatest of all time.
Barry Sanders out of the backfield.
Me at tight end, working the middle of the field.
Red zone.
He's not on here, but Randy Moss would be over the top.
He'd be the guy to put the speed, take the top off the defense.
But then on defense,
my man, Lawrence Taylor. L.T. coming off the edge.
And then Reggie White working the middle...
actually he can come off the edge too.
Imagine those guys coming off the edge, collapsing that pocket.
A quarterback's got no shot, so
this squad right here, I'm pretty, pretty proud of this one.
All right guys, I'm Tony Gonzalez, and I'm here with Sleep Number.
Sleep is something that I prioritize.
I think everything begins, before you even think about
nutrition or working out, you make sure you get a good night's sleep.
It's totally underestimated, but it's something that can actually change your life, literally.
Will make you happier,
will help you make better decisions
and will fire you up. You might not even need that second, third cup of coffee,
if you can get a good night's sleep.
So make sure that you're out there getting your good rest.
And this is: Build Your Squad.